el tabique nasal es una pared delgada
que divide el interior de la nariz en
dos lados el derecho y el izquierdo
Está compuesto por cartílagos suave y
flexible en la parte delantera y hueso
en la parte posterior una capa delgada
de tejido llamada mucosa nasal cubre el
tabique
si tiene el tabique desviado el tabique
está doblado en lugar de ser recto
un tabique desviado puede bloquear el
flujo de aire a través de la nariz
el procedimiento para solucionar
problemas con el tabique nasal se llama
cirugía plástica del tabique nasal
para comenzar el procedimiento el
cirujano hace una incisión en la mucosa
dentro de una de las fosas nasales
luego la mucosa se separa del tabique
para que el cirujano pueda verlo
para enderezar el tabique el cirujano
puede hacer algunos cortes en el
cartílago para relajarlo
a veces es posible que se tenga que
retirar la parte doblada del tabique
el cirujano deja suficiente cartílago
Para apoyar la nariz
después del procedimiento la incisión se
cierra con puntos de sutura
en algunos casos cuando no se retira el
tabique a través de este se pasan más
puntos para mantenerlo recto
es posible que el cirujano le coloque
férulas en la nariz para sostener el
tabique mientras sana
las férulas se retiran al cabo de unos
días
Si desea obtener más información sobre
la cirugía plástica del tabique nasal
hable con su médico